hello everyone and congratulations to
everyone if you are watching this video
right after the podcast but even if
you're not and if you have some two
hours of free time to check it out the
link to the podcast will be in the
description below so like after the
podcast against with MBL we decided to
play one Blitz game so here I got the
white pieces this time and I did prepare
for this game it's a blitz game so 5 + 0
and I prepared the watching some games
he played in the accessible masters I
prepared some Sicilian dragon with with
black maybe maybe if he goes if he gets
white and he goes for efore as I watched
his game against then he'll do both and
then I found some improvement so I
thought maybe I could use that and also
I prepared for some Queen Queen Queens
gambit declined the ideas for white so
as I got the white pieces I went for d4
and like Maxine Hikaru also surprised me
already on the first move he didn't go
for any Queens gambit declined ideas he
went for f5 and he goes for the Dutch
and I didn't really do any research on
the Dutch like ever well I did do some
some Stonewall but as I don't really
know how to play it with white I decided
to go for a 4 right away I sacrificed
the pawn you know in the style of old
masters I'm gonna play f3 in the next
move and try to give up one bone for
rapid development so he Cora accepts
that he played the F captors on e4 and I
go Knight to c3 ready to recapture my
pawn he defends it with Knight to f6 and
I go f3 here I want to give up this
point and then and get some nice rapid
development and here you could accept it
you could play something like d5 also
very popular in this position however he
called plays III he gives the pawn back
however he gives it back by doing by
doing this he doesn't want to keep it
and allow me to go for some rapid
development instead he hinders my
development by forcing me to place my
Bishop on on a weird square so d5 and
the bush of the d3 I just continued
developing and he here he goes c5 and I
thought if I should capture it or maybe
just ignore it I don't know
playing something else in deciding
whether whether he can character whether
he's gonna push c4 at some point seemed
like I like too much so I just captured
it and it's important to realize that he
cannot go for d4 to win material because
I just captured the point and if Queen
captures Bishop b5 check just wins his
queen so instead here there is one game
in the in the database where if I was
played but here he goes for Knight to c6
he prepares e5 for the next move and it
is as a move seven that we have a
completely new game now so I still have
to decide whether this is ever an option
so I just play Bishop to b5 I just am
ready to always remove one of the
defenders of d4 so it's not a problem
and he goes for a five just grab some
more space in the center and now he has
massive central control I'm still up
upon but it's a CC pawn so it's not not
really all that impressive and here I go
for Bishop to g5 pinned this night as
well I I didn't want to constantly have
to calculate what happens if d4 so I
played Bishop to g5 and next I'm gonna
move the Queen Castle queenside probably
and then try to deal with his massive
center he goes Bishop to e6 continuous
development adds one more defender to
the pawn here because I was kind of
threatening Bishop captures and then
just winning the pawn so better p6 he
defends it and now I go Queen to eat you
again with some ideas of maybe
characters or just Queen captures on e5
since the knight is pinned so he goes
Queen to c7 adds a defender to the pawn
here and I Castle queenside again with
the threat of let's say characters and
then I just win the pawn on d5 so he
also castles Queen side now adds another
defender here and here there's a well
there are a couple of ways you could
treat this position let's say Knights
the a4 is an idea adding another
defender to the c5 pawn also interested
interesting is just captures because the
Queen cannot capture because Queen
captures an e5 so he would have to
capture with the b-pawn but I didn't
feel like this was all that much like I
didn't feel like I could to go for some
sort of a queen side attack I'm also
Castle queenside and this just
strengthens his already massive Center
so instead I went for Bishop to h4 I
wanted to bring my bishop to g3 and grab
hold of this diagonal here he here goes
for Bishop captures and c5 he wins back
the pawn so now it's equal material
however he still has a really really
strong Center and as the old saying goes
he who controls the center should win
the game so Bishop the g3 I grab hold of
this diagonal could be very important
later on and he goes the shabak the d6
he just the defends his ePHI pawn and
here Knight to h3 I still have to decide
how to develop this Knight have to get
my rocks into the game so night h3 to
f-22 maybe somewhere could be could be
possible in the future so I go Knight to
h3 he goes rook hd8 and I go rook hd1
and pretty much all of the pieces are
now developed with the exception of me
having a well of a funny night here on
h3 and here now I could attack his
Bishop with 95 so he brings the bishop
back push back the g8 and also he will
have some plans of shifting this Bishop
with h6 to h7 and the grab hold of this
diagonal so I go Bishop to a4 I want to
bring the bishop here and he goes a six
and now I played Bishop to b3 which
could be a bit premature I could wait
for him let's say that to go b5 to then
bring the best back but I decided to do
it right away also possible was King to
b1 just a nice prophylactic move okay
I went Bishop to b3 it's a five minute
game you don't have like all that much
time and he goes Knights the d4 and my
bishop to be removed gave him the option
of now just unpinning as while the
bishop was here I his rook would would
be under attack so here he just unpinned
I go Queen d3 and he picks up the knight
the bishop
Knight character son b3 with trick a
capture son b3 in now just h6 and here I
noticed immediately that of course he
doesn't want me to have the g5 square
for the knight so I just played better
back to f2
and here I thought maybe I could use it
maybe some nights the a4 ideas going to
be six the bishop is also very nice and
this diagonal however he has a really
really really strong move here which he
plays of course he plays Bishop to b4
and now there's a problem just d4 and
well and now I don't have any of those
plans I was hoping for I cannot really
move the night and it's not not all that
impressive
I could I could try and sacrifice the
exchange but I didn't think I had any
compensation for the exchange so here I
played rook to e2 but this rook Tate you
move completely blunders the game and I
thought the the quote above the board
was fitting for this game as well to
avoid losing the piece many a person has
lost the game which is kind of what
happens here so feel free to pause the
video and try to find the absolute best
winning move for Hikaru while I give you
a couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
and paying attention as we already
mentioned this move and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
it's Bishop to h7 and now all of a
sudden my queen is trapped
there's nowhere and there's nowhere to
go I could of course go to d2 but then
just before I run into the exact same
idea that led me to move the rook to e2
so that's not really accomplishing
anything
so after Bishop to h7 the queen is
really trapped there is no square for
the Queen so here I thought about just
resigning but then I spotted one idea
that kind of could keep me in the game I
played Knights to b5 and here I attacked
his Queen also and I was hoping for pawn
captures Queen captures and then I could
maybe again have some threats here maybe
I can bring the rooks into the game who
knows I yeah it's a blitz game at least
I'm still surviving however to my horror
after this night to be 5mu hikaru like
instantly played Queen to a5 and here
it's just game over because the bishop
covers the D 2 square so the King has no
escape square and Queen to a-1 is the
threat of mate while my queen is also
hanging on d3 so there's no escaping
both of these threats again III played a
few more moves Knight a7 check he played
King to b8 and now there is nothing I do
have this fork however there is no
continuation after the pawn captures I
plate c3 I gave my King an escape square
but he just captured my queen I captured
on before again maybe if if characters I
can still hope to do some damage
however he just played Queen to c7 check
and it was in this position that I
resigned
game as there is nothing more to be done
here once once I deal with with the
check he's gonna capture the rook and
then it's just that I'm down too much
material so I did hang in there like for
some for some 20 moves but it's it's
literally like the old saying goes he
who controls the center will win the
game doesn't matter what you do it's
just having the center is just too good
so I don't know I might I might do some
research on the Dutch now that I see
that it might come up in an important
game but I don't know III kind of did
enjoy that
efore pawn sacrifice in the beginning so
who knows I might do some research I
might not but yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it like I said if
you've missed the podcast it's it's a
bit less than two hours so if you have
some free time to check it out the links
will be in the description below we had
we had a very nice talk so you guys
might enjoy that as well I would like to
thank Glenn Wilkinson and Maggie Brill
helm Carl our van Berg Stefano mafia and
Gabriel endure for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the chess
table Masters checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day